Watch out everyone!
Don't get too close to these people.
What are they doing?
Are they fighting?
Why are they wearing the same clothes?
Yes, they are practicing Taekwondo together.
Is everyone the same age?
I see belts that are red, green, orange, yellow and white.
Wow, what do those special colors mean?
Each color represents the different skill level achieved by that person.
Taekwondo is a martial art sport invented by Koreans.
It is the most popular martial art in the world.
More people do Taekwondo than other martial arts, like Karate and Judo.
The word, Taekwondo, means "the way of the foot and fist"
or "the way of kicking and punching."
It really looks like fun.